what else is traits of the total man the
total man does not get caught up in BS
drama
um the total man does not act like a
wussy so uh when things you know if like
David Goggins is like uh I broke my foot
good I'm finishing this hundred mile run
like and though the stories they collect
and pride themselves on are not about
lifestyle balance
are not about like someone came over to
my house the other day and they she said
this to my wife she goes it's okay to
not be okay and I go total man would
never say it's okay to not be okay
[Music]
you're turning into uh Sasha Fierce with
that trying to calm down all right we're
live I don't know who Sasha Fierce is
and I bet she's amazing it's uh Beyonce
when she goes on stage she has a stage
character she calls Sasha fear she gets
into that mode so no matter how she was
before going on stage she's like that
wasn't I'm a new person now and I'm
doing my thing that I do with this it's
hard when you drink your Topo Chico you
take a big Swig of that and you become
Sam fierce
where do you want to go from here you
drive all right I got a couple things
that I want to talk to you about
so
I think I think this episode is not
going to be for this for the faint of
heart I think it's not going to be for
the sensitive I want to talk to you
about a concept that I've seen two
concepts the title of this episode is
gonna be I'm not racist but
it's not illegal right
it's like I'm not I'm not trying to be
sexist but that's what this this episode
so okay so let me show you something so
I'm doing this um
um Workshop that is clearly not a
webinar today right after this with uh
our boy Nick Huber
and um how many people signed up yeah
can you say I guess so you guys how many
people signed up for a webinar
hundreds
five thousand people have signed up for
this no [__] really
your boy pulls weight I think is one
conclusion but the second conclusion is
I saw I got to see up close and personal
how Nick marketed this thing
so Nick does something I call mob
marketing he basically angers the mom
Nick who Nick Huber
um and he's on Twitter he's at sweaty
startup and he's got a big following
couple hundred thousand followers and
some people love him and a lot of people
hate him he's one of our only friends
like we have this group chat of people
who all got big on Twitter he's the only
one of us I think that gets like death
threats on a daily basis dude his home
address gets posted people will post
this on the dress they'll post pictures
of his wife and they'll talk about how
he's evil they'll post on LinkedIn
separately not even tagging him the next
day being like I couldn't sleep at night
just thinking about how much this
bothered me with what this guy said and
he'll say things that definitely ruffle
feathers he does it I would say
it's some overlap I can't decide you
know it's hard to get into the mind of
like you know the Joker Batman what's an
example post it's like so he'll be like
um I've never met someone who has purple
hair and also has their life together
he's like I'm not saying it doesn't
exist but I'm over eight
and so it's like some people think it's
funny
some people are secretly kind of Nod
along but they'll stay quiet about it
and then a bunch of people are like dude
what are you saying here and they're
offended or they're like offended on
behalf of somebody else and then he'll
do that again he'll be like um
you know he'll say I run my company
um I have you know 20 people that are
making five dollars an hour in the
Philippines and it's the best decision I
made
um hiring my my International staff has
has been you know an absolute Game
Changer I'm never hiring entitled
Americans who care about a b and c again
um you know whatever and then people are
like
you're what are you anti-American and
then they're like wait five dollars an
hour in the Philippines do you feel good
taking advantage of this labor and he's
like well you know I'm paying them
double what they were making before this
otherwise they wouldn't take this job
like I'm not forcing anyone into
anything but okay if that if you want to
protect these people who like this job
okay sure
um but the point is is he posts stuff
that he knows he knows Ruffles feathers
he takes a very polarizing approach to
it and I would say in our world in the
business world this is not common
um Elon kinda does it
but not really and he's the only he's
the only one I could think of uh that's
like maybe there's a bunch of other
examples but on the bit on the business
side it's not that common in the pool
political side you see it right Trump
did it before he he was doing it as a
business person well I think it was I
don't know maybe because his whole
business career was kind of pre-social
media so it's hard to say right like I
think he always was this guy but you
know when you do it in dinner parties
it's very different than doing it out
loud on Twitter where anybody anywhere
in the world can follow you and hate you
um Tucker Carlson is like this uh all of
the like kind of media pundits that get
really big Hannity and whatever they
take a very polarizing view on things
Ben Shapiro right and then you have
Andrew Tate and this kind of leads me
into a um so first I kind of noticed
this mob marketing tactic I was like
this is very effective
um I don't know if I would want to do it
it sounds like it you know is a lot of
like kind of firefighting
um and I've been able to make it work
without doing it so I don't I don't
really intend to go do this but it is
one tactic that does work the other
thing that I've noticed with this is it
ties to this idea I call Total man and I
think total man is a new lifestyle that
is popping up and I'd like to tell you
about it so here's the idea with total
man is this a trademark uh phrase I
tried to buy the domain it's taken I'd
like to own this domain
um and I think that
this is going to be is either already is
or going to be the next big kind of
Lifestyle brand trend is whoever owns
this total man thing I think Andrew take
kind of did it so I'm a little bit late
to the to the game here but basically if
you look at the following individuals
David Goggins
Joe Rogan
uh Jocko willink Andrew Tate Donald
Trump even Nick Huber to an extent they
all subscribe to this like total man
lifestyle what is the total man
lifestyle so here did I get did I get
left off that bullet point you you are
you're like half of them
um like I think I think you definitely
you're not total man you're half man but
yeah you might be two percent milk yeah
you might be trying to get to that to
their level okay so here's so my trainer
even said this he's like he's like I'm
just trying to live the quality like I
want to be a quality man and I want to
have this lifestyle I thought quality
man that's a good phrase that I said let
me just sharpen that a little bit total
man I said what do you mean by that he
goes he's like I just want to have my
finances like set I want to have I want
to be wealthy I wanna I Wanna Be Fit
like I don't want to be out of shape I
don't think it's cool to be out of shape
I'm gonna push myself to be in a
phenomenal shape
um
and you know I found some other
characteristics that he didn't say these
but basically somebody who's
Unapologetic so you see this with Nick
when the Bob comes at him he never
apologizes or backs down he pushes back
again Trump does the same thing Andrew
Tate does the same thing they doubled
down instead of backpedaling so they're
Unapologetic why because they live by a
code I think you do that too they live
by a code it's an internal code and the
internal code could be a little bit
flawed like entertain says some wild
stuff but the fact that they have a code
is actually quite admirable I think
people are attracted to somebody with a
code because they themselves don't have
a code and so you it's sort of like life
is easier when you just uh around people
who live by their kid
um what else is traits of the total man
the total man does not get caught up in
BS drama
um the total man does not act like a
wussy so uh when things you know if like
David Goggins is like uh I broke my foot
good I'm finishing this hundred mile run
like and the stories they collect and
pride themselves on are not about
lifestyle balance
are not about like someone came over to
my house the other day and they she said
this to my wife she goes it's okay to
not be okay and I go total man would
never say it's okay to not be okay
Lifestyles right I think there's one
lifestyle and so let me keep going he
knows what he wants out of life and then
he has it so it doesn't matter if what
you want is a Bugatti and uh you know uh
three model girlfriends what matters is
that you wanted it and you sort of
whatever quote-unquote manifested it I
think that's another trait of the of
these people that do this total man
lifestyle and lastly
they have strong Hobbies Joe Rogan goes
bow hunting uh you know Goggins does
Pull-Ups for fun uh these people have
strong hobbies and lastly they are
charismatic and they care about being
charismatic so to me I think that you're
gonna see a bunch of Mega influencers
and a bunch of Brands being built like
in the same way that there's like
right-wing conservative like that became
a lifestyle and an identity and then a
bunch of Brands got built for that
population I think you're going to see a
bunch of people you're already seeing it
with Andrew Tate and others David
Goggins and others that are trying to do
this total man lifestyle
and then build a bunch of products for
other guys who want to be in this want
to be a part of this religion and I
think about this and this isn't anything
this isn't anything new I'm reading like
the biography of Arnold Schwarzenegger
right now and but you know he likes
something he would be in the church if
the total man would do is go read Arnold
Schwarzenegger biography yeah well he's
he's an Eclectic person but he was uh
you know he was selling workout plans
and things like that because people are
like oh you're on the he would he would
do these photo shoots in Fitness
magazines of him holding a surfboard on
the beach in LA and he in the biography
he's like I've never surfed in my life
like I could barely swim look at me like
have you seen a bulldog swim like it
doesn't happen a lot and uh like he's
like you know I don't really like I'm
not like that but
people wanted to look like him they
wanted to be around these hot girls they
wanted to live in LA and he would sell
these plates so of course this isn't
anything new we're just seeing a
different generation here's what I think
is new
um I have this belief that like almost
everything that becomes a big trend is
in response to the world being a certain
status quo in the other way it's a
pendulum that swings and so you had an
era where it was like the world was very
conventional and traditional and blah
blah blah and then you start to see a
bunch of unconventional untraditional
things and this is people having
different genders and pronouns and
purple hair and all this stuff and you
see a big movement in that direction
and then you see
um like I would say therapy and empathy
and all these words have never been more
popular and amongst men and women
um
and I think in response to that I think
there's an undercurrent of people who
feel like it's all too soft the world's
getting too soft we need Hard Men we
need we need the total man and and so
here's how I know it works everything I
described is the opposite of toxic
masculinity
it is basically
uh being a man became something that got
labeled as toxic masculinity and now I
think there's a bunch of people trying
to take that back and be like hell no we
Embrace masculinity and so that's what I
see happening is people basically
flipping that on its head and be like
I'm not I'm not gonna apologize for
being manly in fact I'm gonna double
down on it and then there's this wave of
people who have been craving something
like that and I'll give you the example
I remember when Snapchat came out and I
underestimated Snapchat at first I
thought oh disappearing photos for kids
and is this just for you know bleep
picks like you know what what is this is
this this is gonna be a real deal
what I underestimated was that Snapchat
was the response the pendulum had swung
at when Snapchat came out
Facebook was basically at the peak of
its powers
um or it had like sort of like was was
uh Facebook and Instagram were like the
top and
what Facebook and Instagram were were
every photo is public every photo is
permanent every photo looks good and
just trying to make you look look cool
and what was Snapchat it was the exact
opposite it was every photo is private
every photo is impermanent and it lets
because of that you get to be silly you
get to let your hair down you get to
just send Goofy pictures instead of
pictures that make you look cool
and so that there to me the need for a
product like Snapchat only be only came
out because the world had got so
instagramified so facebookified where
everything was public permanent and uh
and and pretty and so I think that you
see this anytime you notice that the
world goes in One Direction you could
sort of anticipate that two or three
years later
the counterculture response is going to
be there the opposite is going to become
popular and so uh this is like a way for
me to get like when I think about how to
be ahead of the curve on Trends I start
to think about what what feels dominant
today and in three years what would be
the opposite because I think there's
going to be an emergence of that
counterculture what do you think of this
am I just am I just doing fake astrology
there trying to piece things together
uh no your theory I think is is exactly
right you know there's been things that
I've been interested in like um have you
heard of the the Light phone it's
l-i-t-e phone
because I I believe that why because
we're so well I guess explain what it is
but it's like we're so excited the
microphone is
it's like a 300 phone but it has the
screen of a Kindle so no colors and I
think you can only download I think it's
gonna only do spot I think it's just
Spotify I think it's just Google Maps
and then phone calling and you might be
able to text but you can only text like
a Nokia type in like yeah in order to do
c you got to hit one three times right
and it's came out like maybe 10 years
ago at this point eight years ago and it
didn't really hit right away but it's
getting more and more and more popular
another one that I've been preaching
about forever and it hasn't entirely
taken off yet is DuckDuckGo so
DuckDuckGo is a search engine it's just
like Google but it's uh you can't be
tracked and so if you Google DuckDuckGo
internet searches they actually have a
graph and you can see like the number of
searches per day it was growing
exponentially right
um yeah so your theory I think is
totally right I think anybody fashion or
whatever is going to know this they're
gonna be like yeah duh like when
everything goes to skinny jeans guess
what's guess what's coming back next
and whatever the you know the baggy
stuff the high-waisted loose stuff or
whatever
um but you have an issue here's a here's
a flaw with this premise this particular
one it's not a flaw
you're stuck in this California bubble
man you gotta you gotta come to where
I'm from in Missouri I think like you
know this is this has been gaining
momentum now for a little while I think
the difference is is that
um California types you know the people
like if if I'm from like a place that's
generally right of center now the left
of center people I think are also
craving a bit more than before right
before it was like kind of cringy guys
um and then
they start evolving a little bit to
being a little bit more holistic and so
for example
do you know who Andy frisella is yes
so he's in our world and that
technically we compete against him in
the podcast charts but I had no idea who
he was but he was the he was the he's
the number one business podcast
typically in the charts each week and he
talks at a ton about like politics and
stuff and I I believe he's right of
Center but it's that's mostly a
stereotype of just the way he looks and
some of the phrasing that he uses his
podcast used to be called the mfn CEO
right and then I started listening to
him and I'm like oh you're way more
eclectic than I originally judged you
for and you're actually really
interesting and I think that that's
what's happening is that there's uh
people who don't entirely fit into the
previous bubble of of of whatever I
would stereotype these guys as being
right which is like lower IQ big ass
Meat Heads it's like Oh no you're
actually way more thoughtful than I
thought totally uh yeah I think that's
that's totally true
um so yeah I think this uh I'm keeping
an eye on this and I think that they've
been very successful like David Goggins
is kind of like stunningly popular now
and um same thing with
did you see Andrew take came out of
prison and did an interview did you see
this interview on BBC
it just it ended mid-interview didn't it
well there's the full thing got posted
on like rumble or something like that
like what happened yeah no I didn't
watch it I mean it's kind of a headache
the thing about him is like he started
out like if you listen to his messages
like
maybe 70 is like good like you know a
man is someone who exercises they get
what they want
but then like there's like 30 where I'm
like ah bro like I don't want to be
associated with that like that you cross
the line there but uh yeah some of the
stuff he says is awesome so for example
yeah the the BBC so it's a woman she
comes into his home and she's
interviewing him
and uh she goes you are you know um
how can you say these things that are
you know toxic and dangerous and
whatever you've been named by the UK
um commission uh Committee of whatever
as the most dangerous man in the United
Kingdom you he's like dangerous man in
the United Kingdom he's like oh he's
like he's like what am I preaching that
that is so dangerous he's like he's like
I don't I'm Muslim I don't drink I don't
do drugs I tell people don't drink don't
do drugs I say work out I say work hard
get rich
um and you know like build yourself into
a quality individual who lives by code
and he's like you know that's what I
that's what I preach what is dangerous
about that and she's like well you said
on an interview that um
if your wife does only fans you're
entitled to half her earnings or
whatever
um or like that you know if your wife is
your wife that she is your your property
as a man or whatever and he's like he's
like did you listen to the actual
interview and she's like you said that
that is that's what you said he goes yes
but what's the context of the interview
the context interview is uh are the
context of the podcast is I'm me and
several women are on a podcast we're
joking around because one woman says
um if my man owns a car and I'm dating
him that's my car I own that property
too and then he countered as a he's like
he's like I basically as a joke counter
if I'm dating a girl and she hasn't only
fans then I I get half of that too and
uh he's like well the same logic right
and he's like so that's what I said and
she's like so are you saying it's a joke
he's like yeah I'm saying you're taking
it completely out of context and he's
like you know he's kind of like trying
to defend himself and they're arguing
back and forth and he's like he asked
her a question and she's like no I'm
asking the questions here he goes no no
you're in my house I invited you here
I'm doing you the favor you know you're
begging me for energy views and I I let
you in here we are equals uh there you
do not hold any authority over me we're
equals if I ask you a question you you
can choose to answer if you ask me a
question I don't have to answer either
you know that's how this is gonna it's a
conversation and she like was like
rejecting that premise and then you hear
their handlers in the background that
are all like getting really nervous
about how the whole thing's going
because it's like going off the rails uh
the BBC Handler or the Handler because
it he he has them yeah he has people who
are like you know I wouldn't say maybe
Handler's not the right word but like
you know he has this like kind of
whatever is PR type people that were
like he's answered the question already
like why like you repeated the same
question six times like just move on to
the next thing like you're stuck here
like he's answered it he's not going to
answer it any differently he's answered
it five times now just move on to the
next question and so they were like you
could hear these voices in the
background in the unedited version like
even they take a break they're like hold
on we gotta the camera camera died we
gotta reset the batteries hold on and
then
you can see what happens in the break
she like immediately is like no it
doesn't make eye contact she's like
looking at her notes only
it's fine it's fine no this is good
actually I want people to see how this
goes he's like I want people to see her
uh like you know how how the mainstream
media how they don't they don't do their
research they live online he's got his
like Spiel but during the break there's
like maximum tension it's like that's
actually probably the most interesting
part of the whole interview so I uh I'm
not con I'm me personally I'm not
convinced I'm willing to sign up for
that I don't want to I'm not I don't
want to deal with that headache agreed
I'm willing to make sacrifices to some
parts not of my code it's just that my
code is like not that hardcore maybe
it's the right way to put it but I've
met a lot of people who run companies
that you know that are worth hundreds of
millions and some that are actually
worth billions and I'll see them like do
certain things that are common now about
like uh
uh like they use phrases like bring your
whole self to work which is like kind of
like a funny controversial statement to
some people because some people like no
just bring your work self to work like
we don't we don't need it
yeah or no there's like a crew and then
there's like they'll do like certain
things that are typically like uh that
you see a lot of better get categories
as woke and I'm like dude I know you
don't believe that and I I see them say
they'll say things privately like
yeah but I want to win and this is the
game I have to play in order to like
hire all these people and I don't know
how I feel about that when I hear about
that I'm like I had a funny uh
experience with this so when we got
acquired by twitch
um now in a 2000 personal organization
and twitch uh literally I think uh you
know five percent of the staff has like
you know purple hair like and that'll be
that's a knock I just mean like we're in
San Francisco We Are The Stereotype of
when people talk about like
kind of like left leaning social media
companies like people think this about
Twitter or Facebook I would say twitch
is probably more like that than um in
terms of the staff so I'm in a meeting
and I joined like three minutes late as
I do as you know that I that tend to be
three minutes later every time and um
there's a presentation on the screen I
don't really understand what's going on
I'm like what is this presentation about
and I'm I slack somebody and they're
like oh it says like a you know just
kind of like updating our copywriting
whatever I'm like oh copywriting I love
copywriting what are we talking about
and it was talking about like how we use
uh genders from now on it's like we only
say they and then go off and then they
were talking about uh women they're like
we don't say women we say
um and they spell this word
w-o-m-x-n and I was like how do you even
say that what makes it I don't know what
is that or is it just women like what do
you say for that and like this is now
how we say this and I was like I was
like what does that mean like sorry dumb
question like like what is it who's if
who's offended and what does this mean
it's like oh this is inclusive of like
people who were maybe not biologically
born women but now are women and so this
is like the inclusive term and I was
like so I was like I was like how do you
say this and and like all of a sudden I
could see I could feel like a bunch of
heat on me like why are you asking all
these questions and like there's kind of
an undercurrent in the way I'm asking
the questions which is sort of like is
this are you sure like that's kind of
all I was I was like I was like wow this
is overnight we're just changing like
this is we don't say that and now we say
this like this is a pretty big change no
and um and so I'm hearing this and I'm
like okay I guess you you know that's
cool and um and then they the funny
thing is the company then tweeted out
for international women's day they
tweeted out International women's day or
whatever right like they tweeted it out
like that and then they got tons of
blowback from the translator like the
lgbtq community being like don't do
don't use that phrase just call us women
why are you trying to make it seem
different
I was like oh my God they're back like
their attempt to to like you know
placate actually backfired and I was
like wow this is really like this is
there's a bunch of landmines like you
know you don't even know but then what
did the executive were you like hey
executive team what are you thinking you
can't ask that but I was like I said it
in a different way I said uh we're
talking about like you know questions it
was like um Amazon has this thing where
when you are doing your yearly planning
one of their questions is what are the
dogs that are not barking yet it's from
this old Sherlock Holmes story of like a
crime occurs in a house there's a
break-in and there's no clues until I
can't figure it out and he figures it
out because he's like
um well the dog was here right so surely
the neighbor heard the dog and they're
like no the dog didn't bark
he's like Ah that's it that's the clue
Watson and he's like what he's like if
the dog didn't bark it's because he
knows who the Intruder was that means
this was an inside job and so he figures
out who it was because there was the dog
not barking so they have this thing in
Amazon which is when you're doing your
annual Planet they said what are your
dogs not barking basically like what are
you not hearing that is actually telling
you something
um or it's a different way of saying
like what is a something what is
something that's not being said out loud
but could signal something that's worth
yeah yeah and um
so I said I go I think we should decide
how woke we're gonna be and like where
like is there a line and what does that
mean and who do we want like we should
say it out loud what we want to be
um
my slack just blew up it was like DMS
being like like abort I [__] don't
don't say this like don't break this up
like um what are you saying dude like
this is like you know uh a suicide
mission and one girl goes she goes she
goes um I didn't appreciate that we
don't use the word woke anymore
and I go like a wee who like there's a
company policy you can't use the word
woke I was like I didn't even mean it as
an insult like I thought it's just like
yeah because at the time it really
wasn't this was many years this is like
four years ago or five years ago now and
bulk was woke became a little bit more
derogatory over time uh at first it was
stay woke it was like a the kids were
saying it as like yo you if you're not
you're not like awake to what's really
going on dude I think Twitter had
t-shirts that said stay well yeah it was
like a positive thing and then it turned
into a criticism later so somewhere in
the middle of that and I was like we
should decide and she's like we don't
use the word woke anymore so I you know
I appreciate if you don't do that okay
who's we is there a committee that
decides what words we can say like that
sounds pretty non-woke to me and uh and
she links me like a Vox article I'm like
oh you read this Vox article yeah you
decided that I can't say this and I was
like oh this is just too much for me and
I was like there's only one piece of
advice that I needed it was a piece of
advice I got on this podcast from a guy
very early on Daniel gross he's super
smart guy he got acquired by Apple and I
go what was that like in that
acquisition and you were there for three
years what what was the best advice you
got about navigating that and he goes
don't give yourself brain damage and I
go what he goes yeah when you get
acquired there's a really tempting thing
as an entrepreneur to like I'm gonna I
see things that are wrong in this
organization or that I want to be a
challenger voice and not just like
another another person who just follows
you know the company line and I'm gonna
challenge you know maybe our Innovation
cycle or our policies or anything I'm
gonna I'm gonna be the one who brings
change he goes it's just brain damage
don't don't try it and I was like oh I'm
doing it I'm giving myself brain damage
how'd the woke story end it ended with
that one person telling me that we can't
say say these words anymore which was
backed up by nothing and I was like oh
cool so you read this article and so you
decided that I am not allowed to ask
this question again gotcha just
clarifying great uh thank you you know
whatever head of
important thing inside the company like
yeah I'm glad that you're uh I'm glad
this is how this this works and you know
what do you think without calling out
well Emmett is the CEO and he seemed I
don't know him but he seems like an
awesome guy but I don't know if you can
answer this without calling him out but
what do you think he thinks or someone
like him can I say someone like him
someone in his position someone in his
position with his name and face what
would they say yeah I don't know I can't
speak for him but I I guess my
impression of it was basically I think
he's mostly shielded from this stuff so
like I don't think the most of this gets
to his plate and that by the time it
does he's he's a total man he doesn't
care about drama like
I think he's he's like a renaissance man
he's a little different
um I think two things I think one
I think he's mostly just like um
he I think he's gotten a lot of CEO
coaching to where he doesn't let his
first reaction be his response so like
something comes up and now instead of
reacting he responds and usually
responds with the question and he'll
just ask them tons of questions and he's
like I'm in the spirit of literally
understanding what you're saying and
trying to figure this out
tell me what does that word mean like
and they'll be like it just I mean it
means inclusive means that you say well
like no like can you please like use an
example or can you uh like from can you
explain that from like you know base
principles like what are you talking
about where what are the boundary lines
like let's make sure we're all talking
about the same thing and uh he does look
kind of like a Socratic method where he
would he would end up just like
fatiguing out anybody who wanted to
bring something up and he would get his
understanding of it and the decide is
this important or not but um I think
most people are sort of intimidated by
him and then in the process of trying to
debate him on something would sort of
like
nobody could really a very few people in
the company could really like hold up to
any debate or any scrutiny from him in
in a conversation I saw it just many
many times and he was trying to dial
that down because he knows that that's
like you know already he's in a position
of authority plus he's like uh you know
world-class or debater who's got this
like wide breadth of knowledge to like
pull from so he already knows he's like
you know if he does that she's gonna
shut people down so he's trying to tries
not to do that but I saw you know most
people didn't want to bring it up to him
dude I just avoid all of this this [__]
like I can't stand this stuff and it's
just I just don't care is it really what
I guarantee it's just the worst part of
the job for Zuckerberg or anime or
anybody who runs these networks like the
one percent of trust and safety or like
angry people that's constantly angry
about something that's got to be the
worst part of the job that's not why
they created these networks is to like
be a public policy maker in their own
like Kingdom
but it is amazing how they uh get around
it uh because I could I could tell Zuck
doesn't care about that stuff but he
still plays the game yeah and sucks a
man he's never had a controversy he's
never done anything not a lot of these
guys haven't uh like they've done pretty
good with navigating some of these
topics and I'm amazed that they don't
react by saying oh you guys want to form
this Union or you want to like protest
over this
you're all fired like this is a machine
you know we don't need this we don't
need this this is right like didn't he
he say something in an email which is
like you know
let's not do it this way and then he got
fired from his own company what happened
I don't I don't know what happened he he
was he wrote an email to the staff about
a trend he noticed in the workforce
which was new hires had to introduce
themselves using their preferred
pronouns he says
this is completely unnecessary for a
woman who is clearly a woman to tell us
that her pronons are she and her and a
man who's clearly a man to tell us those
pronouns are he and him
um
he understands that the practice is Root
in kindness but he says in the long run
this approach does more harm than good
because you're forcing people to behave
a certain way and that's the opposite of
inclusion
um
and then
and so then uh
he says first there's a tidy number of P
of people at uh well he says peeps so
you know already that's a fireable
offense it's a tiny number of peeps at
pale chimp who would consider themselves
transgender forcing either with orders
or guilt the other
1390 other peeps to adopt the can you
communication the humanity has never had
to use in our 300 000 year existence and
our 150 000 years of spoken language in
order to make things slightly more
comfortable for an extremely small group
of peeps is completely illogical
um
so then he got fired it was probably for
the peepsieg to be honest
like into it whoever bought the company
was like look man we need to talk yeah
he's like but I didn't mean to hurt the
the trans people he goes what no I'm
like we need to talk about this p pig
yeah he stepped down as CEO shortly
after and uh voluntarily uh and then
also then somebody came out I was like
by the way there's no policy that says
they have to do that it's like [__]
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
we um one time at the hustle we wrote an
article on Sasha Gray Sasha Gray used to
be like this famous porn star and we
wrote about how she was trying to change
her image around to not be that and
every single night at like midnight our
time I would get all this traffic from
Japan because I guess that was morning
time in Japan it was all people
searching for Sasha Gray and they were
fighting our articles yeah and I found
out that she had hired this company
called like reputation.com to like boost
that article so it showed up first so
we're getting all these people searching
Sasha Gray XXX and
they didn't get what they wanted to but
whatever you're like photos at the
bottom of this blog post it's photos
inside our newsletter if you subscribe
dude I didn't realize I guess I realized
it but someone posted this infographic
on Twitter of the biggest websites and
it was like Google was just like the
largest it was like bigger than
everything combined but then like
I think four of the top ten were were
porn sites and uh it's it's wild I mean
imagine working at one of those
companies can you imagine that what
would that be like just sitting in the
office we imagined it many times no um
so I've been I can't talk about these
but I've been I've had very interesting
conversations with a few people that own
only fans based businesses recently and
they're absolutely crushing it to the
point where I can't talk about it
because I would be kind of like
it's like
do you mean do you mean the the stars or
like the ancillary things oh most I'm
talking about the ancillary things right
now but they're all crushing it the
platform is crushing it the stars are
crushing it and the the cottage
businesses that get built around this to
help this either to be a part of that
ecosystem but they're doing so well that
I sort of if I talked about them I would
be coming between them and like millions
of dollars because people a lot of
people would want to compete with the
the strategies that they're doing but I
will say one thing that I have learned
that was pretty interesting so I always
assumed that only fans was popular
because
um you're sending like I don't know nude
pics or videos to guys and that's like
the thing that's what they're paying for
and I was always a little curious I was
like porn's like free on the internet
why would you pay for this like uh there
must be something I don't know and I
just kind of wrote it off as that do you
know why they make so much money do you
know what the actual Money Maker is
inside of a of an only fans account when
these girls say that they're making like
a million dollars a month you know what
actually drives that
I've never I've never subscribed to one
I guess you probably have subscribed to
a few now that you're like researching
it but I've never subscribed to one you
know I'm a married man and I did not do
that but uh you didn't need to because I
talked to the people who like run they
like run the accounts or whatever like
what a lot of people don't realize is
that a lot of these accounts are just
they're bought so like uh uh girl has a
public Persona she doesn't only fans she
kind of gets exhausted running the thing
because it's like a lot and it's like
emotionally exhausting dealing with all
these guys and uh whatever so she's uh
so somebody come approaches her and says
we'll buy your account for um
yo I'll give you 200 000 right now for
your only fans account and then I'll
give you you know X percent of the
profits and I'll run it you just have to
put pictures in a Dropbox folder and uh
you give me good content and I will give
you money and that's how it goes and
then uh and so what what actually people
so I was like why do people pay for
these pictures and videos like again
porn's free that's like one of the rules
of the internet is porn is free uh so
what what do people really want and it
turns out that
they want
like the girlfriend experience and so
yeah they not through the content but
through the chatting and that the
chatting has all kinds of weird things
like is it one group chat or individual
no individuals and so they hire Farms of
chatters so basically what only fans is
built off of like a lot of the the money
is made through is
giant like customer support you know uh
call centers uh essentially in the
Philippines
talking to you know it's basically like
Dunes in the Philippines talking to
dudes in the U.S pretending to be the
girl and so they it's just like they
have this Army of chatters that will
chat with these guys and tease them and
flirt with them and then upsell them and
boom to Ching got the sale there and
they're like sales people they got to
they get commissions and all this stuff
it's insane and what how within that
okay so one of the highest ticket items
what's the you know if this was the the
county fair what's that top stuffed
animal at the top and it's basically
like the number one is pretend to be my
girlfriend for like you know a month and
it's like text me as if you're my
girlfriend
um and it's like that's the that's like
the top prize but there's other weird
stuff underneath
we're so weird that I can't even say
this this is a family show
um and so I can't even say some of the
weird stuff that they want but it's not
what you would think it's not like super
crew is it just like sending sending
pictures back and forth like I'll give
you one example one example is the guy
who's the customer sending pictures to
the only fans person
asking for their opinion a rating of
them and that's like the service that
they pay for and so there's stuff and
and I guess like the two things stood
out one is
it's like the free market at work baby
it's like you you can really see what
humans are all about when you talk to
this to these people because it's like
man people are into all kinds of crazy
stuff these are like their real desires
and these are desires they wouldn't
admit and I bet a bunch of these people
are you know they're the person they're
doctors and they're the CEOs and they're
they're other people like you know human
desires got revealed they were always
there and they got revealed because only
fans gave a a
a better Avenue to to realize those
desires which is kind of crazy to me the
second thing is
I
think it's wild how much money is being
made in this space and
um my reaction to it is not kind of like
like I think you were asking what's your
reaction to
no my my question is not who cares if it
exists my question is uh you getting
involved into it what how does it make
you feel and how does it make your wife
feel and are you like involved in it
well okay you're you're contemplating
I'm learning I'm talking to these people
because I find it fascinating uh I have
contemplated investing in some of these
because I was like I would not want to
operate this but yo if you're if you're
already down there in the sewer let me
know if you got something I'm gonna hand
it up here you know like I I will I'll
provide resource dude do you realize how
hypo that's so hypocritical why is it
hypocritical I'm saying I don't
personally I would not personally enjoy
operating this I I also would not like
in operating a deli or an ice cream shop
or whatever but I'll go I'll go eat a
scoop what's the problem with that
if they need resources they need capital
or they need advice I'll give them those
things I don't want to operate so to me
that's fine
um my wife it's also hypocritical of Me
by the way if I consume porn into also
[__] on it so I'm not acting like I'm
holding I'm not acting as though I'm
holier than now but it is a conundrum I
told my wife by the way I was like hey
I'm thinking about this and she just
goes okay don't tell me but if it makes
money that's fine
um
yeah I would also say that it's really
funny uh I find it like amusing the way
that the ecosystem Works where it's like
what you think it is is
some woman with an account who's putting
up content and guys want that and then
she's chatting with them and it's like
actually this like whole other thing
there's agencies that control the
accounts the agencies are 90 dudes uh
the Chatters are like you know these
call centers in India and the
Philippines and um I find it amusing I'm
like that's hilarious that that's what
this like
that that's how this like evolved and I
find that dude and I always I always get
their reels on Instagram at night in bed
so like I try not to keep my uh so I I
like if I'm scrolling on my phone at
like 10 pm it's normally like rip guys
and dogs in the day and then even in the
evening it's hot girls that pop up on my
real or you know like when you're
scrolling through your Instagram right
and I'm like wait what is this and then
you click on their profile and it links
to a link tree which goes to well the
funny thing is you see it because what
they one of their main growth tactics is
they pay meme accounts so accounts that
just post funny jokes 99 of the time
the way that those accounts make money
is only fans people will pay a lot of
money to get posted one time at night on
those accounts and then you can delete
it in the morning
um and that's how they grow their their
own social followings and so uh through
these meme distribution channels and so
that's a funny part of it but anyways I
don't even know didn't plan to talk
about this one but that's a funny little
tangent so all right listen
I don't know if this actually is going
to interest you but I'm going to try to
make this interest to you because
anything that uses the H word history
you're not into the right that's not but
the total man should understand history
because history he actually listen he
actually you know has been alive through
all of history
so I'm reading this book it's called
like killers of the flower moon it's
basically about the 1920s Osage Indians
there's Native Americans they were given
this plot of land when they were like
you know like the government was like
Hey you know we're taking this [__] over
here's your plot of land turns out it's
sat on all this oil and so they all got
rich and white people
take advantage of them and kill them and
to steal their money and I was reading
this book and they keep talking about
the pinkertons have you heard of the
pinkertons Never So they well I kept
talking I was like why don't they go to
the police and they're hiring these guys
called the pinkertons so pinkertons it
was basically a guy named Alan Pinkerton
he started this company in 1950 and he
started it because he was walking
through the woods one day and he saw a
bunch of like counterfeiters and he got
curious so he starts watching them and
he starts figuring out what they're
doing and then he calls the police on
him and they're like well we can't
really solve this he goes give me a few
weeks I'm gonna I'll keep an eye on them
and I think I could figure out what
they're doing where they're going and
I'll be your detective he does that and
they get arrested and he's like I love
doing this this is very fun and so he
keeps doing it and it starts like a
small like little mom and pop business
where he goes to other people he goes
hey do you want me to help you solve
this crime just pay me a little bit of
money and I'll go and I'll go and do it
and we'll report it to the police and
we'll give them all the evidence that
they need so he does this for a handful
of years
and eventually he works his way up to
like the uh the government American
government is paying him money and it
gets to the point where his people this
is pre-secret service his people uh
protect a blanket so we didn't have the
Secret Service back then Secret Service
was invented after Abe Lincoln got shot
didn't do a great job
yeah
it turns out yeah
I want them all get what I'm all turns
out yeah that is actually totally true
he's had a bunch of losses but uh so he
so he was like uh uh failed to protect
the president but for some reason the
government still liked them so they
start giving them contracts so anyway
fast forward
to the pinkertons are still around and
they've done a bunch of controversial
[__] so like as they grew
companies like uh Andrew Carney like the
titans of uh industry would hire him to
basically like when they were uh unions
that would go on strike they would
literally sit outside of a gate of a
factory and like like protest and [__]
and then also fight and so the
Pickerington is at one point killed like
24 of these like protesters it was like
a huge thing and so they're like bring
up a note here that says at their Peak
they had more agents than the standing
American Army is that true that's insane
dude they had tons of people and their
motto was pinkerton's don't sleep we
don't sleep and their logo wasn't was it
was it open eye and so they like it was
just like we're we're there all the time
uh and we will always find out what's
going on you know I thought that Mighty
Ducks ducks fly together was the top but
uh this we don't sleep might be better
than ducks fly together
yeah we don't sleep but so this company
was created in 1850 I think I said I was
reading about uh coincidentally this
other thing going on with like Amazon
Amazon was having some issues with Union
stuff and dude Amazon this company still
exists and Amazon hired these pinkertons
so basically what they do now so the
company was sold in like 2005 or
something for like 400 million dollars
so not a significant amount of money for
how long it lasted but because it kind
of peaked in the early 1900s
look at their website have you been to
their website
it just says our story and there's
literally a picture of Abe Lincoln
that's the heroinette
do we have a home about owning you're
phoning your failures these guys love it
yeah yeah
it just says whoops
we've learned from our mistakes
nobody nobody feels faster than us
yeah they took fail faster a risk
advisory investigations protection
embedded smes I don't even know what
that is that sounds dude so listen to
what they do so they basically they'll
hire these guys so Pinkerton like
there's like guards now I guess I don't
know what they wear like balloon jeans
and a plaid shirt and they like go to
like they'll go to Starbucks hire them
and they'll go to the Starbucks to get a
coffee and they'll just try to listen in
and you'll hear like one guy talking to
his co-worker like hey we should
unionize or you know [__] this guy let's
do this and that and they go and report
it back to like corporate headquarters
or they'll try to figure out like when
uh Amazon was launching a bunch of stuff
they'll go and just walk around the
office and be like is anyone talking
about some [__] they shouldn't be
talking about and they like report it
they still exist Google hires them
Facebook hires them they still like
monitor monitor this stuff and it's a
really it's a fascinating that a company
has existed since 1850 or whatever it
was and they're still like working and B
I started thinking about like
private police and security companies
and there hasn't been that many like
interesting security startups so one of
them that I actually invested in it's
called Deep Sentinel do you know what
deep Sentinel is it's the security
um it's the security thing where you're
like it's a security camera where uh
it'll talk it'll like there's like a
human watching on the other side uh deep
sentinel's whole thing like they make a
joke they go Ring's awesome for watching
your [__] get stolen and uh like I I
have deep Sentinels at my house and like
one time a drunk guy came up to my front
door thinking that I was we were his
Airbnb and like the camera like catches
him and he says Hey sir what are you
doing here and they call the police so I
walk down at like 3 A.M and I see the
cops at my house like taking away this
guy and so anyway that's kind of cool
another one is called Banner man have
you heard of banner man I have heard of
this it's like bodyguards right
dude we used to do it all the time so it
was a company that went through uh White
combinator and one of those conferences
well I don't know I'm trying to figure
out the site's still up but basically
when you host a conference by law as
well as like practicality like you need
it you have to hire security you need
security guards and we would use
bannermen and we would hire like and
they have like a menu it's like armed
guard 200 an hour non-armedgar 150 just
a huge scary looking guy 100 an hour
like you could like hire them by the
hour and it was so easy it was like uber
for security it was awesome
but there hasn't been that much new
startups like in this space By the way
here's the pricing unarmed guard 59 an
hour armed guard 98 an hour off-duty
police 145 an hour and they're armed
that's it that's it so I just get a big
scary guy to walk with me for 50 bucks
or 80 bucks an hour or whatever it is
I'll do it for free
um
uh so anyway I'm just like interested in
this space and I thought like the
Pinkerton think it was wild that this
[__] still exists you know how much they
sold for is that or do you know anything
about their revenues or anything like
this is a crazy no and I've looked
everywhere and the founder uh he he says
uh on his LinkedIn he goes I don't use
LinkedIn anymore that's like what it
said on his profile so I Founders alive
yeah his name is Johnny chin
um how is he alive 1850 Oh Oh I thought
you were talking about uh [__] Banner
man uh no fingertips no dude for sure
Dad uh how much does it cost I don't how
much well you said sold to somebody
right was it 400 million dollars in 1999
400 and like 99.
um but it's pretty fascinating that it
lasted that long it got sold so
basically and I was doing even further
research on this that like there's this
like
the security industry it appears as
though it's like
a handful of big players and then tons
of mom and pops but the handful of big
players there's like three of them and
they each do like 10 billion dollars a
year in revenue and what they do is they
just acquire tons of like mom and pop
businesses and so now the biggest ones
you'll you'll probably recognize a lot
of their T-shirts because they'll see
them at like
um
concerts and [__] like that but then
there's a bunch of private ones I've
heard of Blackwater no that sounds good
though so dude this guy his name's his
name's Eric Prince very controversial
guy uh I haven't read his book but I
want to but he was controversial because
he started like a it was basically a
private security company but they did
[__] for overseas so they would like uh
protect like princes and Saudi Arabian
[__] like that and then also when Iraq
and all that [__] went down they would
do government contracts and so they
would eventually like you know do army
[__] so they would like protect like a
convoy and eventually kill a lot of
people and they're like hardcore and
Eric Prince uh became a billionaire
doing this and he eventually sold it to
private equity for billions of dollars
it's called Blackwater very ominous name
I love that name yeah there's like a
there's like a bunch of interesting
players in this space but not that much
like of these like Tech startups so I
think it's really interesting and
fascinating industry
uh I'll give a quick shout out to this
genius restaurant uh so this guy Joshua
Goodfield tweeted this out there's a
restaurant that basically named all of
its like the number one the number two
the number three
um office supplies so it'll be like mini
dry erase board or like pack of pencils
so that's hilarious you can expense on
all meals from this restaurant it's
called a USB Wired Mouse five dollar
french fries yeah exactly
I thought that was a genius little uh
little marketing hack
uh so shout out to that and then um dude
are you watching the NBA Finals I get a
little little human interest story for
you uh
no but but tell me about it it's pretty
crazy so the two teams that are in it
Miami Heat Denver Nuggets so
um the best player on both the teams
have just like crazy backstory so
um one there's a guy in the heat Jimmy
Butler he um have you ever seen the
movie The Blind Side
I love that movie that's my favorite
movie it's his life so the guy got
kicked out of his house at like 13 and
was crashing on Friends couches and then
this white woman just took him in and um
she just like joined their family and
he's like yeah she's you know she didn't
have to do that she just did it um he
calls her mom like you know his brother
her her real kids or his brothers and
sisters like that's just like the way it
was and he was not like unlike The Blind
Side with the Blind Side it was like it
was pretty clear this guy had like NFL
Talent like he was just like a freak
athlete and it was huge and so any coach
would kind of tell you that not to say
that's why she did it but like it was
kind of like possible but Jimmy Butler
was like he wasn't like he went to a
junior college then he transferred to
Marquette and then he barely got into
the NBA and now he's a star but like it
was not obvious have you heard do you
know who the real parents and blind side
that you know it's real people he owns
he owned a shitload of KFC's and like
Long John Silver's and [__] when I
Googled him he sold it for 400 million
dollars all of his franchises
this woman that took him in single mom
also so single mom with seven kids did
this took him in basically put a roof
over his head and uh he ends up grinding
his way to the NBA and his you know
doesn't make the thing he also is doing
something really really funny so back
when covet hit the NBA to keep the
season going they had to create a bubble
many sports had to do this they created
a bubble which was like a basically at
Disneyland yeah they did a Disney World
I think so they did it in Disney World
in Orlando it was like you live on on
campus nobody comes in or out like if
food gets delivered it gets delivered in
a like sealed box 30 feet away and it
gets you know like given to you and they
just like tested everybody daily and if
anybody ever had anything they got
kicked out
and so during during that process Jimmy
Butler realizes
yo Supply demand is out of whack so he
starts he's making coffees he brought it
he brought a fancy coffee machine and
starts making coffees and um people are
like yo can I get some coffee like the
coffee here sucks I want the good coffee
he's like yeah cool man it's a hundred
dollars
hundred dollars he's like what's the
price to go he's like these are NBA
players who cannot leave this bubble and
so and they're like all right man [__]
it they just are giving him a hundred
dollars for this coffee and so he
creates this brand I think it's called
big face coffee uh he and now he's like
so he he and during the bubble people
want to know what it's like in this a
lot of the guys are like vlogging so
this was like one of the story lines yo
Jimmy opened up a coffee shop he's just
like you know killing us on this coffee
and he's like yo I make the best coffee
it's best coffee in the world 100 and uh
and so now he's like creating a spin-off
brand of actually that that coffee brand
there's nothing kind of cool
that big white guy the giant white guy
so uh yokich dude he looks mean that guy
looks mean I saw he got into it small
town in Serbia
he got into it with some dude on the on
the sidelines too I saw uh yeah that's
funny that was the owner of another team
he basically like bullied an owner of
the another team so um so this guy's
he's awesome so he basically his story's
even crazier I think so this guy's born
in the middle of nowhere Serbia he's got
two older brothers
and um
his he's even though they're really tall
he only likes one sport
horseback riding so he's just falls in
love with horses he's always on the
horse track or whatever but because he's
so tall like uh you know when he wasn't
on with the horses he starts playing
basketball and
um
what's interesting is that nobody would
have ever known to this guy except for
the fact that
um there was one team that had a
business model and their business model
was basically let's find prospects that
might have like NBA we don't care if we
win now but let's just find like big
dudes he's got a lot of potential that
like might get bought out by the bigger
clubs and let's they're like kind of
like house flippers they're like let's
buy this guy let's see if we can turn
like you know polish up the asset and
let's flip them to a bigger team in
Europe or let's hold their rights and
maybe we get their maybe the NBA team
will have to buy buy us out and they've
done this with a couple of guys and so
the guy's reading the newspaper one day
and he sees it at some youth basketball
game like says some eighth grade game
some kid you know had like 25 points and
25 rebounds and he's like huh so he goes
and he finds this guy and he's like hey
you ever thought about playing pro
basketball he's like no and he's like
come with me so at like I don't know age
13 he like leaves his hometown and joins
this like team and they're like and so
you're so then you think the story is
because he's the best player in the NBA
now so it's like he must have been he's
the best now he's the best way in the
world right now and so it's like how
tall is he he's like seven seven foot
one something like that and so they're
like you would think oh he must have
been dominating in Serbia and then like
you know he went to the these like you
know tier four League he must be awesome
no he didn't even play the coach was
like this kid is so fat he is just so
out of shape I will not play this guy
and so he's only allowed to go to
practice and they're like until you can
run like until you're in shape or it's
not gonna work he's like uh what do I do
like well what's your diet and the guy
was drinking like two gallons of coke a
day he's just who's addicted to Coke he
just loved Coke drinking Coke and so
they were like you gotta stop that like
first of all and um and so he he stops
drinking Coke he loses like 30 40 pounds
in the course of like a few months just
by changing that like one habit and
we're going and running every day in
practice because he won't they won't
give him the ball he just have to run on
the side while everybody else practices
and so he's doing that finally he um
starts playing he becomes like the top
player on his team team like as soon as
he like was able to get in shape he was
the top player on his team and he gets
drafted in the second round like
basically he's like one of the last
picks in the NBA draft if you go watch
the video of like oh I want to see when
they got drafted like you've seen when
LeBron gets drafted he gets on stage he
shakes the commissioner's hand he smiles
the light bulbs are flashing like people
know this is the start of a star is born
what was he just like walking by and
they're like uh here take this hat here
just take that one even better they just
cut to a Taco Bell commercial and at the
bottom ticker it just said pick number
41 Nicola jokic it's just like it goes
across the screen it goes away and it's
a Cheesy Gordita Crunch
if anybody would have that starting
moment because nobody thought this guy
would turn into anything and then he's
basically become you know the best
player in the world so how old is he
it's only like 27 28 something like that
he's pretty young still and um he
actually wouldn't have even made it to
the NBA like this team in Barcelona was
gonna buy him that was going to be the
flip it was like he goes from the
Serbian team to the Barcelona team and
the date like the day before he was
supposed to sign the contract like it
was already the lawyer just had to
finish one thing he played in a game he
was so terrible that the team backed out
so he had no choice but but to go join
like the NBA team that had bought his
rights or drafted his rights he's like I
guess I'll go to the NBA then like you
know I I don't really know if anything's
gonna come up this but whatever and so
he goes and he's this very stoic guy
like in all his interviews they're like
they have these the media has all these
narratives they're like
how is becoming a new dad helped you
become a better basketball player
he'll just look at something like what
it doesn't that's that's not how that
works it's just like he's like just very
matter-of-fact like you know like you
like the kind of like dagestanding guys
in the UFC he's kind of like that but
for basketball so he's a fan a
fascinating character it reminds me of
this quote that I heard from this this
VC I was like you know what's uh he had
this Twitter bio
um this guy Nico uh Nico I don't know
how he says
I know exactly how you said from uh
General Catalyst yeah from GC exactly
the guy he invested in Snapchat super
early on and um I was like Nico why is
your bio why is your bio quote what it
is and his quote was
um Talent is everywhere opportunity is
not so his talent is evenly distributed
but opportunity is not
and I was like why is that what does
that mean to use it because it's true he
goes Talent is everywhere but
opportunity's not evenly distributed and
if I do my job right we're going to
distribute opportunity to more people
who have the talent and I think about
both these guys the two guys that are
starring in the NBA like you know
they're kind of like one little bounce
of the Plinko chip away from it being a
zero and instead they get to be world
famous basketball players it's like if
this guy didn't get discovered while
playing in like a youth farm league in
Serbia or Jimmy Butler didn't get you
know adopted by this woman like who
knows if they would have ended up
actually even getting their shot
um it's like that's how fragile like you
know like success and failure can be
dude last night I wouldn't uh hung out
at this like uh have you heard a float
track or flow Sports sorry fellow Sports
yes so flow Sports uh started as um
uh it was basically this guy would go
they started out of UT University of
Texas this guy would go and film track
meets and wrestling meets stuff that
wasn't going to be broadcasted otherwise
thought that wasn't going to be
broadcast and he was just like uh he was
a track and field athlete and I think
they had friends that were wrestlers and
he's like but you know I'm I'm a fan of
running and like people love that [__]
but just not on TV so he starts filming
this and then he puts it online and he
forms a company and people start buying
it and paying like 100 bucks a year to
watch this stuff and it's been around
for 13 years now and now they do over
100 million in revenue and I was like
what's the fastest growing segment and
he said uh
uh
um Motorsports and I was like oh like
NASCAR and [__] he's like no it's like
these like it's like the pre NASCAR so
it's like where the 18 year old kids
they do this thing called dirt track so
it's like it looks like a buggy kind of
it's like he's like it's Grassroots but
he didn't say it but it's like redneck
[__] and he's like that's our fastest
throwing segment but we have like 18
Sports I think they have wrestling
grappling running across country trying
to feel whatever all this stuff and so
he um I went and hung out their office
because they had a little party and I
was with like three different guys who
had won gold medals in the Olympics one
guy in the decathlon one guy in the mile
and uh some other guys
and first of all
here's what was interesting one of the a
bunch of the Olympians I was like hey do
you still run you know they're like
maybe 40 now and like you still run and
they're like not a chance like it was my
job and like I don't want to do that at
all anymore like I'll exercise and go
for walks and I'll lift weights but I
don't want to like run like I used to
run I'm done with that and the second
thing was interesting is like dude these
guys are all freaks like one guy his
name's Trey Hardy you can look him up
his body is crazy and they are freaks of
nature but
it's cool being around people like that
who are a the best in the world at
something like they are literally if
they won a gold medal at that point they
are the best in the world at what they
do and it's so fascinating to like hear
the stories like they would tell stories
they're like dude that guy we used to go
to the hotel and he'd be wearing
flip-flops and he'd be like hey I bet
you could touch the ceiling and the
ceiling was 15 feet high and he would
just jump and just touch the ceiling and
they were like we just would see little
like things like that this guy would do
[__] all the time or he'd be like watch
this I bet I can backflip but he would
backflip but he would jump so high in
the air and like we would just see these
like freakish stuff all the time
and so I was thinking
would you give up any of the success
that you've had so far in order to be a
broke but Olympic medal winner or like
the best athlete or whatever in the
world because I was thinking about that
and I think I would
no chance on the uh the gold medal well
best athlete in the world yes I would do
that that's but there's a lot of sports
where you could like be the best like
NCAA wrestler or best like
an overall athlete no no if it's if it's
uh I'm I'm the fastest Miler or NCAA you
know uh Nation you know National
Champion or whatever no chance I've said
this before the Olympics are for suckers
oh you are so crazy because I'm hanging
out with these guys and I'm like
congrats you are the best bobsledder the
world has ever seen you've dedicated
your entire life to this absolutely
arbitrary thing that got you that got
you nobody that got you uh you know no
no skills Beyond this dude I'm so I so
disagree because they were asking me
advice on business [__] I'm like hey
just so you know I'm like the hundred
thousandth most successful person in
America maybe like that's what I want to
do I want to play a game where the
hundred thousandth person wins and has
an awesome life not where I have to be
the best person in the world and even
then I gotta start over at age 27 and
create a new career because I'm done
with the thing and my joints don't work
anymore these guys had shaved arms and
shaved legs I was just scared at those
calf muscles and I was like dude I could
see every video Forum that's so awesome
I would kill to have that I want some of
that vascularity like look at that vein
pop like I just love this cool uh his
business advice is great but then he
said he wants to put butter on my chest
I didn't understand that they kept
saying I had a really nice and ball cast
at the top of my leg like dude their
calf muscles were just so solid a little
tennis ball was stuck in there I just
saw that I'm like I remember I was
thinking of this one guy and I told say
after I was like dude I bet that guy's
wife is so hot like she just she's like
you said to your wife
they're so lucky well and then she's
like well he worked hard and I was like
no the wife that wife is so lucky
can you believe this she gets to see
that bad like I was just thinking about
that [__] man and I just love these
Olympians man I don't give it all up
just to be to be a gold medal in the
high jump
so I don't know where we go from here
this is The Tall Man episode
of loving men
I do I like I can't you see a guy with
like you know like some sick calf
muscles you gotta admire it you know
yeah I guess you I guess you do you
don't do that
yeah definitely not the way you'd
like there's been several people that
come on this podcast and I'm like I'm
pretty sure Sam's just imagining them
without their shirt on right back yeah
you got some sick pecs bro how'd you get
some of those things yeah if I see a guy
a big packs I just want to ask him a
bunch of questions uh
I don't know where we go from here
[Music]
laughs